hello everyone welcome to new rockstars
news I'm Eric vas oh it's Sam bash over
here oh and this is a weekly roundup of
all the big news that has come out in
the nerd world and guys what a week it
has been I have never seen so many
trailers drop within a seven day period
of course we the the big game on Sunday
where we had a couple things but it's
like everyone was like going all in from
the different studios like oh you have
you have a Deadpool trailer I got a
venom trailer that's not ready to
release yet but here it is anybody got
visual effects we got something we can
play with images of a Tom Hardy jogging
in the woods that are really anxious to
we're gonna dissect and break those down
there oh yeah yeah we got we got
in-depth breakdowns on all of the
trailers that have come out in the past
week that are separate videos on this
channel so like click an easy one some
are already out some will be out very
soon if they aren't by the time you're
watching this but in this video we're
going to watch all these videos and just
react to them and give you what our
first takes are what we think this movie
is going to be how excited we are to go
into this movie so let's just the first
trailer dropped during the big game this
is a surprise Avengers infinity war
30-second TV spot so let's take a look
so this is good it's all been leading us
ready let's go
[Music]
I will say right now that was my
favorite trailer from the big game there
were a lot of good ones but that was the
one I rewatched multiple times I feel
like that not really saying anything
there was another one that was released
I think it was dialogue from all of the
major heroes and it would linger over
their face when they were delivering the
line yeah the person yeah and it's like
oh you kind of get a vibe so you know
that your Scout Johansson is now blonde
little snippets like that new looks yeah
caps beard those particular things but
at the same time you don't really know
what's going on yeah vision is human
well yeah like a few questions like that
but in terms of storyline you really
have no idea left in the dark unless you
know like the infinity Wars trailer
concept which I kind of think is
refreshing because so many professors
you watch and you're like well I've seen
them maybe the main thing is hey
everybody it's like hey it's slogan it's
Avengers infinity war yeah everybody
everybody's here yeah well except maybe
Hawkeye and ant-man but they were there
somewhere Archer ranges just practicing
that move from Civil War over and over
again they tried so hard to make
hawk-eyed more popular with age of
Ultron I liked his stuff in that but I
didn't do too well yeah but III agree
with mod that this it's light on plot I
don't know how much we need to know this
is what I loved about this 30-second
spot is I mean that you can see in our
breakdown that we did a bit there's
about as much like interesting like
detail in it that if you're really
looking hard that would be in as would
be in a full-length trailer so like it
does as much to get you excited this a
lot of people were talking to us about
Tony Stark's new armor which a lot of
people compared to the bleeding edge
armor in the comics it's each time in
these movies it looks like the armor
assembles in some new way and I liked
how similar look to the way to vibranium
armor assembles on black panther be
interesting to see if there's some kind
of connection there I kind of hoped that
his glasses like disappear into a suit
too cuz he's taking him off like it was
more like cuz it's growing over I'm like
you can do whatever it wants also one of
my favorite shots is Thor looking up
there's a lot of really cool there's a
very cool cinematography in this I don't
know why it's such a simple shot
nothing's happening we'll see you stay
on a keyboard but I yeah like it's like
yeah that seemed from big but instead of
a different keyboard the universe is
dying it said but I do like that they're
withholding a lot of stuff also they do
a I like that they're showing that this
is much bigger than any one person
specifically with Spider Man's in space
he's in space there's nothing he can do
like if he tries to jump he might die
like that's what's gonna happen so yeah
I like that this is you everyone's gonna
need to help each other out yes New York
down there yeah what a crazy jumped up
there put on his old suit and it zipped
up in the stratosphere no yeah I love
this over it reminds me of like when the
that Red Bull super jump just you could
see the curvature of the earth they put
a lot of thought into how these things
would be storyboarded yeah we know is
that Marvel's done such a good job
telling origin stories fleshing out all
of these heroes we know so much about
them so now it says all right and you're
all together so you're gonna have those
massive nerd payoff moments where you're
like oh my god
Thor's meeting the gala got into the
galaxy cruise so like those the teams
that you've never really seen in the
same room before I think that's how you
can re excite a fandom he's by giving
them and yet separate and now together
and there are going to be the key
moments and you've already seen that in
in this movie yeah with that the
original shot where everyone's running
and you're like wait a second is little
kantha Hulk's back there yeah okay
Bucky yeah there's so many cool little
Easter eggs in that and I do like yeah
this it's just like oh cool now you get
to see the mix of both like tech and
magic together I was doing Doctor
Strange and Iron Man yeah yeah like he's
he's making a shield and then iron man
just blows right through it like kind of
knocks him over maybe exactly looks like
he's kicking over the Sandcastle bit
there yeah maybe but I think it'd be
kind of cool if he was maybe like
enhancing his suit to do something else
like that you want to see those kind of
like Power Team Team ups yeah it's hard
to tell if it's like one guy setting up
the football field one to punt or the
other one is like no no don't you
just smell you don't know what its gonna
do that's my friend don't do this
yeah it's hard to tell whether they're
working together or there's a team
writing so you don't know there's
somebody else that's saying right next
to him so who could that maybe this is
gonna take place after like panthis I'd
be interesting to say what happens in
the Black Panther movie that carries
over into this one as well and I'm just
amazed to see that Disney spent millions
and millions of dollars just on this
30-second spot and they already know
we're gonna see this movie like we know
we're I'm more excited for it but it's
not like it that turn right like did you
really get the return on investment for
spending this much money like yeah yeah
we don't have Inoue seconds during the
Superbowl we already know that you're
gonna go see it I think the biggest the
bigger trailer was like three minutes in
16 seconds which is almost a whole full
minute longer than the average trailer
that's released yes like that just
packing it in and again it's like just
jointed little Clips it's not
progressive plotline yeah well we have a
breakdowns for both the Avengers
Infinity Ward big game TV spot in the
trailer that came out back in November
so make sure to go watch them for deeper
dives into all the details that you
might have missed but for now let's move
on to the next to the trailer to come
out this week or solo a Star Wars story
something we've been waiting to see for
months and months and months finally
they released it they released a shorter
teaser during the big game and then a
longer trailer the following day on
Monday I'll say I I kind of enjoyed the
the big game teaser a bit more but we
got a bit more information in the more
extended trailer so let's take a look
I've been running scams on the street
since I was 10
kicked out a slight Academy
for having a mind of my own
I'm gonna be a pilot
best in the galaxy
hey kid
I'm putting together a crew
you win that's yes
that might be the only person
who knows
what you really are
[Music]
what's that
[Applause]
get ready now we're in trouble there for
a second but it's fun we're fine
all right yeah we all agree that uh
Lando is the best
I really want a Lando movie really bad I
want dongle ever to be Lando forever
yeah I had I've just edited the movie
and they've just kept all of his scenes
and everything else and just kind of
like switched it around a bit yeah the
actual Han Solo moments are my least
excited moments like of the trailer I
just
yeah actually totally I think the Lando
moments the other droid that's gonna be
going with them on whatever this mission
is I think whatever he's like little
minor is everything looks puppeted which
i think is also yeah very fun touch yeah
the it looks very practical as opposed
to a CGI and we don't really know too
much about this Troy to believe it's
name is L 337 just like kind of a lead
reference or I wish I wish you just like
poured out all this informations like
you've seen only 37 I'm like that has to
be a joke that they can't be I don't
know but yeah it feels like what they
nicknamed it on set they're like oh we
just called it Leda but anyway I loved
the the little synchronized salute there
we we found that that was something that
Billy Dee Williams did in the showers
earlier Star Wars in the Millennium
Falcon huge distance them constantly wet
lips well as for this trailer I think
that we were talking before it Sam you
mentioned how you like the way it's
edited more than what's in there yeah
what I think guardians of galaxy right
yeah it seems really fun I like the last
15 seconds a lot I think
Alden Ehrenreich stake on Han Solo in
those final shots is probably better
than what I saw in the rest of the
trailer he's kind of saying hey we're
fine we're fine
they did it I think that's almost a
direct Pole from something han Solo said
in the original movies and just that the
big goofy space squid thing just feels
very Empire Strikes Back yeah it's a
it's space they don't need to breathe in
space um I hope it's more Empire Strikes
Back and not Phantom Menace in the
underwater scene as always
the official I am yeah I'll tell you
what I can't stand though I want to be a
pilot well that's not what the solo we
know I'll give them the benefit of the
doubt that like it's still young Han
Solo he's not Han Solo yet I even had a
theory and the breakdown that maybe his
name might not even be han solo in it
they don't say Han in any other
promotional footage which is not saying
much they just released a teaser in a
trailer no one calls him Han it's just
called solo and all like the
descriptions of these videos and the
promotional releases they only call him
solo in it I'm wondering if like it's
gonna start the story he's gonna be like
another one of these anonymous like from
nowhere heroes who gets his name and it
creates his identity in it I'm just a
fan
I enjoy it I didn't I didn't really feel
that I like the ticking of the music
until it got to the weird like fast it
felt like someone really quickly dilated
the sound and like the speed of the star
wars-themed something to put it over the
solo title card yeah wasn't the fan of
that and you did say you like the last
15 seconds with what he was saying but
like it's like the camera lingered on
him too long he was like huh what's that
oh I didn't like that what's that yeah I
that was one moment that they it was
weird that they kept the camera on the
actor for that long cuz that moment did
not work for me I did like him dropping
that like like yeah dropping the
scoundrel and he's actually a little kid
who doesn't know what he is yet but I
don't know if you're gonna give an
acting moment to one of your leads in a
trailer it has to be one that really
works like Donald Glover got so much
more out of just that little grin in the
way he was sitting like that is lando
and I didn't get that with Han circles
around Aaron Aaron are just make and I
think that's the real problem
you know Curie
what's her name Daenerys Targaryen
Emilia Clarke thank you I mean she's
kind of only really done like a handful
of movies and Arizona
the show so it's like is she gonna be
able to lift him up as well and I have a
feeling if lenders only in a little bit
of it and not like the entire thing yeah
I don't know I just think that Disney is
like who should Elena I think Alden
Ehrenreich task is a lot tougher to give
them you know some slack here like Billy
Dee Williams created such like a simple
a bit less dimensional of a character
than Han Solo is a character who we've
seen explored not just in the three
original films but and yeah the force
awakens and all this expanded universe
now now Legends content that Lando has
you have a lot more freedom just to kind
of do a simpler kind of take on yeah
this is what Billy Dee Williams did he
showed up he was cool and I'm just gonna
do my take on that not too betrayed you
know good story
trust me yeah I hear what you're saying
with it's like Lindo you've got a lot
more to play around with it a lot more
flexibility with the character because
we have had you know more than three
movies I think four movies with Han Solo
and you've seen him you know being the
original home solar and then the Papa
Bear home from though the problem is if
all of your movie is banked on a person
and a character that has exist and
Harrison Ford is still alive today you
need to get the perfect person to cast
that yeah I don't think they've done
that I don't know if it's possible I
mean what we'll see I think Alden
Ehrenreich has potential I think he
could surprise this good to stay
positive I thought Aaron Edgerton had a
great like suave look to him and he
basically just add a wig to Taron
Egerton they look like this yeah kind of
the same dude so like I thought maybe
one of the guys was saying Ansel Elgort
looks weird
well we'll see I mean Woody Harrelson's
in this movie guys he's always great
right and that's who he is it was very
easier detective a little bit yeah a
little bit well let us know what you
think about this trailer and yeah go
check out our breakdown of solo star
wars story we tried to translate some or
Abeche yeah which is always fun Sam I'm
super excited about it but yeah it's uh
if you look there's a Mandalorian helmet
and there was some more batch letters
that I could use your help translating
I'm not much of a translator on that but
we're all in agreement there but let's
move on to another trailer that came out
during the big game one for a Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom we we got a trailer
for this back in December they released
another trailer Sam did a breakdown of
it that is on our channel you can go
watch but for now let us take a look
[Music]
do you remember the first time you saw a
dinosaur we don't really believe it it's
like
a miracle
something's coming
mr. X is the direct
we'll come with me you know you can't
stay here
Jurassic world the island
you're our easy girl all of that is in
the past
my dad I get kid
I want to show you the future what is
that thing they made it
you need to get us out of here think
about it like you've got horror themes
at the stop and then that ended on
comedy and then you had like action
blockbuster in there and then it's a
psyche to be fair so is kind of drastic
park it's very scary it's a scary it's
comedic and it's a little all of it like
we love it it's it's part of our
childhoods and for some of you before
your childhoods but yeah I think this I
I'm excited it's got it all right I'm me
then do stop screaming I will really
tune out her movie fast I like the joke
that he screamed they lined it up with
the Tyrannosaurus fun fun joke and then
immediately she does it again and like
us to stop
I get I'd scream too if I was falling
off a cliff but I want her to be a
better character she was actually the
weakest part from the last Jurassic
world movie I found a lot of the
characterization in that movies really
not great even oh and like but she like
come on take it
put on some sneakers you're running
around in Ireland come on that's not
fair yeah the I'm glad that they're
moving on with the kids I think the two
boys were my least favorite part of the
first movie I mean this kid he can
scream could be it was Jake Johnson
though because he played the techie like
this guy's a techie guy you have a
computer that's what it looks like I did
a breakdown in Jake Johnson played the
same role glasses everything and he was
act he's an actually really funny actor
to be fair I don't know who this guy is
very well his character's name is
Franklin
but I'm excited for the movie it is a
lost world though they're taking the
dinosaurs off the island and then you
can see a bidding war happening which is
what happened they're like they moved
them to a park but now they're just
gonna sell them off it's a very similar
movie literally repeating the fist
I love lost world that's my favorite so
you could notice or run around San Diego
that's the coolest one as prime yeah
he's always in his prime Pro oh yeah
these characters name was prime
optimist you know kind of like the solo
trailer they use John Williams's old
score in this new way I feel like in 15
years we're only gonna hear John
Williams music in these movies or
Michael chiquinho doing a sampling of
John Williams I mean I love the yeah I
like it better in this trailer then I
didn't hunt so I felt like the Star Wars
main main theme was a little weirdly
used where is this they did a very
similar thing with the Clone Wars words
like they just kind of changed the the
beats of the music and it was the same
song but like not what you expected us
you kind of get used to it and I had
that same feeling with what they've done
now but yeah you're not used to it the
first time I heard the clone wars
trailer I was like yes of it the music
box version of the theme though I really
like the universal kind of leaning into
their monsters and their their horror
movies cuz them in bloom house they make
all their yeah all the horror movies
that are so popular I like even they're
even operating on a dinosaur which is
exactly what they did in lost world with
maybe t-rex like their big shot for shot
I'm totally fine with that though why
would Chris Pratt need to jump through a
t-rex his mouth to get out of anywhere
why it was like come on why I know why
because he was coming down the hall and
then they were like it's a box and he
was coming back got to get past and he's
at quad he must have known the t-rex was
in there though so go on the outside of
the box yeah you cannot apply logic to
any of these characters behaviors and
even in the first Jurassic Park like
people are just all over the place on
the least right can I point out in the
video but if you watch from here when in
the bedroom with Owen and the girl if
they calling the endo Raptor when it
walks in if you go a little further back
it walks in it steps down on some toys I
think that's a t-rex and I think that's
like a fun yeah like oh this one's scary
yeah this Way's a beat one music box
function I actually think Westworld did
a lot better with that ooh
run away actually yeah what we'll move
on to that but let us know what you
think of a Jurassic world fallen Kingdom
this you can check out Sam's trailer
breakdown for a lot
Goody's very I'm very excited by it yeah
and and we also we talked about the the
first trailer when it came out and yet
let us know what you think quick
comparisons to what we've seen so far
the most views of the different trailers
that we're talking about
yes something lamp there for sure but
yeah let's move on from I guess one
Michael Crichton inspired terrorizing
theme park to another one Westworld
a great thing to be known for all the
spooky theme parks yeah
okay yeah so Westworld season 2 trailer
released by HBO with a release date
April 22nd very excited about it
let us take a look same night as
Avengers mm-hmm look at this sounds like
a curse on this view it is a comment
yeah it's runaway
[Music]
now I've got like a cold or dreams come
true
oh you can be free
in a minute oh it's all
this world deserves to die
[Music]
which is this is your
we've lived by your promise Molly
keep your agent safe this one
[Music]
we can burn it to the ground
from the ashes demeanor
[Music]
our world she can see us hello okay so
yeah that is a Kanye West runaway we
have a trailer breakdown coming out very
soon that digs into what the song means
and a couple things that you miss so
keep an eye out for it but guys what do
you think I actually like the Edit of
this trailer a lot you have a very very
very slowed down portion of what I
believe would be just one episode
all in all it'll be about six seconds
but they've stretched it out and then
kind of like interjected little bits
throughout it I think that's very clever
West world's always been visually
stunning yeah and that's great
I always just wondered at the end of
season 1 for West bought it's like well
again you're gonna expand a park or make
different ones but the story kind of was
so complete that where do you go now
well the whole point of the movie in the
book was that the robots immediately
revolt like that like that yeah there's
no buildup of like this mister you don't
see how it happens you can see the bay
it opens where the park starts going
amok in the first 15 minutes so the
story hasn't started yet
so rights like we had there's still a
whole book in even extended things to go
through in the retail so there's a lot
but I this show was really hyped up for
me so I watched it after everyone had
was done talking about it
so I it didn't grab me like a lot of
other shows do I'm still interested
because of this character may 10 didn't
yeah she's amazing in this show so I
just want to see more of her doing
things she is great I like I can't get
enough of this show I wish that we had
done episode by episode breakdowns we
were able to give him some deep dives
into the timeline of it for those of you
who don't know there are some it's some
fun complex timeline storytelling that's
going on
it is a Nolan production it's Jonathan
Nolan it's a Christopher Nolan's brother
and JJ Abrams is executive producer Lisa
joy Nolan was an amazing writer as well
as a co-creator of it they a Jonathan
Nolan actually cut this trailer he
produced it he was behind the he wrote
the dialogue forty storyboarded all of
it
so you can tell the difference with
trailers that where the the creator the
project is actually behind them versus
like a most trailers that you see on TV
in the internet are cut by different
post-production houses who specialize in
this kind of thing I'm like finding John
Krasinski back there and we saw a
Suicide Squad where there was a
production house who cut a new movie
essentially I they did such a good job
on that trailer the Bohemians are
absolutely that they gave them all the
footage of the movie to recut it yeah
yeah it didn't totally work out there
but this definitely does feel like an
author created this this is totally
consistent with the show
beautifully crafted trailer that
presents some interesting mysteries that
you'd mentioned samurai world that was
one of the things promised at the end of
last season I do believe there is a shot
of it that we see in this trailer I
won't tell you where exactly gotta watch
the breakdown for it but there's a lot
of fun stuff that does call back little
lines of dialogue from the first season
the the charging Bulls is a reference to
something that I go into it's this move
or this whole show I think asks more
questions than it answers I think that's
a big concern I have with it as a series
going forward like we saw with the show
like lost the first season was so great
because as a storyteller it's easier to
ask the question than it is to present
the answer it's what JJ Abrams does best
and I think he believes in the whole
idea the mystery box said we never need
the answer but I think we do need the
answer the three seasons right that's
the whole point of storytelling you got
to deliver on the promises that you make
and I think the first season did deliver
on enough promises I hear you're saying
mod it did feel like a really complete
story I'd I don't know if I would need a
second season of it as a fan I want it
you know I want to see more of it I want
to see all these actors and these
writers tell us more of these stories
and what happens next but if it didn't
continue it does end on a very
interesting note right and a very like
profound statement about artificial
intelligence and humanity so as long as
they're able to like deep in this
mystery I'm okay with it it looks like
they might be jumping around a bit with
different timelines
I don't need more of that I don't need
like hey the scene that you're thinking
is taking place in this timeline it's
actually taking place thirty years
earlier don't need it more that that's
something they did with lost in the
fourth season or it's okay this stuff
that you think's taking place in the
past it's taking place in the future and
like at this point I think the fans who
are watching the show are smart enough
to see that a cast of coming so I of the
trailers that we saw aesthetically this
is my favorite but it depends on who
your feelings on the first season of
West world on what how excited this gets
you I would say I'm fairly excited
Avengers is still my favorite trailers
let's move on from a trailer for season
two of one show to season two of another
show Jessica Jones music oh yeah
this is a trailer that I'm very excited
for let's in air during the big game and
let's take a look or know what aired
actually after the big game during the
week but let's here we go
glass tonight put it on my tab you
drinkin to remember forget giving won't
get you a better tip can't help highway
my whole family was killed in a car
accident
someone did horrific experiments on me I
know this super vigilante keeps coming
at me
do you know Captain America
I want to absorb alias investigations
you don't want me you just want to
eliminate the competition
I never take no for an answer how rapey
of you something happened behind these
doors I have 17 years of questions and
they are deep just knowing what was done
to you might help you we were made here
me and something else
the only way to find it is to open the
door wider
[Music]
the powers were side effect how many
errors are there like me let it go there
is a killer you cannot control I didn't
ask for any of this
Jessica might not want a sidekick but
she needs one you're not super time keep
telling me who are you
how dare you
what if AC needs me works what are you
gonna do I don't know depends on if I
can get through this night without
losing my it takes a monster
to stop the monster
what did they do to us very conjuring
with that yeah yeah oh yeah yeah that's
great yeah so I'm super excited I'm
Jessica Jones is of the Marvel Netflix
world my favorite series I mean I like
all of them for different reasons I
don't like all of them but you know we
don't need to say that we like iron fist
but I really love Jessica Jones I love
the aesthetics of the show I love the
use of color in the show I love the the
characters seem especially the villain
killgrave and wink at maybe in all of
the MCU I would I would say he my god
boy this is a technically MCU but in the
Marvel adaptations that we've seen I
really love kilgrave but I love Jessica
Jones I love the side characters on the
show this is it's a heartbreaker you
have the most twists and turns of
anything because it's just like how
utterly frightening is killgrave it's
like it's like it's such a great idea
it's like what if you could get whatever
you want it it was just like that's
precisely the premise and it's like but
if I can't get what I want somebody else
can and they had that their entire life
they have no grasp how reality works
anyways that's the premise of the first
season the show so you can go watch that
this that Jessica Jones I don't know if
I said this on her off camera but she
has very few comics out in there for
story like do he explored she was in the
background of a lot of other stories or
she played a supporting character like
spoilers and comics she and Luke Cage
end up getting together and so whenever
Luke has a story she usually so it shows
up in it as well but it's like you don't
get to explore too much so the idea of
exploring where she got her abilities
has never been touched on it's always
just been like there was an accident she
got them she lost her family and then we
move on from there because it's more
about her trauma not about what she can
do and that's what's been so compelling
about it but using it as a tool of her
trying to explore what happened to her
family or trying to deal with that
dealing with a grief or PTSD which is
what I'm guessing is what's happening
with kilgrave unless there's some stuff
I put in my breakdown that could lead to
some other fun stories for kilgrave
because David Tennant's amazing I'm so
glad that people who didn't watch doctor
who now
no how could if an actor E is because of
Jessica Jones so mm-hmm
very high very much hopefully he comes
back but yeah and I just heard a lot of
people watch so we don't really know
what the ratings are because Netflix
never really tells us how many people
watch whatever shows I worry that not as
many people watching Jessica Jones as
people who are watching other Netflix
shows and they definitely did to check
this I'm so glad they're doing a second
season of it the only show to get yeah I
wouldn't win for it wasn't right
interests the trademark covers that they
would know them and oh man it's a very
good anyway she's still won an award so
it counts yeah for me the first half of
this trailer was actually way too vague
it's saying a few blips and pieces but
it's kind of throwing this at you and
you're like oh I'm not I don't know how
to be invested in this cuz it didn't
really kind of provide enough exposition
if you haven't seen season one which is
what I think it needs to do especially
when you're putting out a trailer like
this big week it's fresh eyes on a new
thing but for me the second half really
delivered yeah oh yeah and I think it
did a really good job with that
you're not just invested in jessica
jones but you know who was this blonde
girl that wants to be the sidekick you
know that kind of expansion on it all
the only problem is when you have a sort
of y'all Negative Nancy again but when
you have a protagonist that doesn't give
us that kind of is defeated and depleted
and you know turns to booze to kind of
self-medicate for me it's really hard to
stay along for the ride because it's
almost masochistic because this person
is putting themselves through all of
this like numbing situations or like
they're not looking after themselves and
I actually struggle to to go along with
that I remember reading scar tissue and
there's another one I think it was like
Sugarman or a book like that which is
all about people that have drug abuse
issues and I feel like I can't breathe
yeah me it's just really kind of hard to
come on sport let's go what's next
episode it's a sake no G consequence
kicked when she's down so I kind of want
her to give just care a little bit more
and it sounds like we're gonna get that
with
find out about her family and who she
got the powers yeah fun theory for who
that woman is that she's talking to and
then if you watch ends up kicking into
that door so if she could take a kick
from Jessica I think she might have more
to her there's a fight there's a very
fun like name connection thing that
happens in this trailer and from just
reading the Wikipedia this it's a very
fun anyways watch it break down what are
you doing yeah yeah ChaCha
the if it's not on the channel yet it
will be very soon yeah you're right she
definitely does get completed or and
whoever this guy is the the kind of
shady guy the creepy guy he's there's
literally he his character name and
everything has not been released yet so
it's very interesting to see what he
does I like his characterization this he
seems very slimy yeah well um let us
know what you think of this trailer go
check out Sam's breakdown and yeah back
for season 1 this channel actually did
do a couple videos about Jessica Jones
that you should absolutely go check out
I think is before I was here so yeah go
check those out let us know what you
think for now let us move on to another
trailer came up this week for Deadpool 2
was titled meet cable introducing us to
Josh Brolin's
other Marvel adaptation character this
guy is gonna be all over the place in
the month of May but yeah let's uh let's
take a look at this not safe for work
trailer that we're recreating field goal
post for whatever this is I don't know I
have to explain let us watch
I was born into war right into it people
think they understand pain but they have
no concept of it what's the most pain
you've ever felt maybe the gun that
leaves you more uneven man wait no stop
what in the actual ass why it's a metal
arm it's not like we remove a mustache
hey cable I'm from the future
oh no sheriff Deadpool you know you're a
lot taller in the shut up you little
[__] - this regeneration powers
activate
that's not something simple I got the
stones to help you fighting they're done
already
oh wow that was unrealistically fast
okay yeah
time's up you don't well that's just
lazy writing so yeah this is super fun
I'd forgotten how fun the marketing
campaign for the first Deadpool was
until I see these trailers like these
are almost like non trailers and how fun
they are like so fun and like when we we
have another breakdown of this there's
so many like little jokes that we Spidey
there's references to infinity war to
Justice League one story yeah it's all
over the place but what they'll do is
they'll do just these bits and then like
crammed together 20 seconds of like 80
shots of like the action in the movie
just a little little pet peeve not that
I dislike this trailer anyway it's just
like both of the trailers they've done
it's like a funny bit and like really
funny and then like the quickest clip
show of something I'm like but I want to
see it
what are you show me what that is but I
think that's what we're here for it's
almost as if people knew - we're gonna
click through frame by frame and explain
what everything is which we did as best
of our ability oh great dominoe doing
casting for cable I was like I really
like Kyle Chandler really like McSteamy
is like potentials and I was like I just
don't know about Josh Brolin cuz you
know the whole he's already been in a
Marvel movie kind of deal but Jonah Hex
as well at DC uh really really loving
the look I think he's gonna be a lot of
fun and these balance of having this
biggest smartass the screen has ever
seen biggest time but but also having
like this man who's just cranky and just
doesn't have like any time for humor I'm
capable in decimal in the comics it's
such like a brilliant team up because
they yeah it's the exact kind of like
buddy-cop style arrangement of someone
who takes everything way too seriously
and someone I just take anything
seriously
so it's brilliant that they're using
that it's almost a no-brainer if
Deadpool worked this is the next step
you
you got a show table he owned it Paul
yeah you need a like you kind of had a
in the first movie had Colossus being
like the whole like he's a good guy and
yeah I was like a foil for Deadpool
being who he is but then you flip it and
you get the guy who's way too intense
it's gonna take it way too seriously
like I think we mentioned before when we
talk about Deadpool that like Cable has
one of the most convoluted histories
it's like his parents are Cyclops but a
clone of Jean Grey not the actual Jean
Grey but a clone and then the from the
future where you saved the time but he
got a a manufacturer tech no virus
that's why it's got metal arms and stuff
it's like that's not a robotic arm he
grew that and it's like just and the
teddy bears from a baby he raised but it
was technically his like clone it's like
oh my god just keeps going going right
it is the most like convoluted it's like
the incarnation or just the perfect
example because comics like this is it's
the most bizarre and they just keep
going deeper I think they the the
writers of this story might just start
having fun they're like okay well we've
already gotten this far let's just go
off the deep in and I think that's part
of the fun of bringing him into the
Deadpool universe which who's already
part but like into his storylines and
like let's just put them in someone who
doesn't care about the continuity the
this trailer I think is edited so well
because they it's a true trailer I don't
really know too much about the story
here I know that cables coming in I know
there might be some time travel element
that probably will just be more made fun
of than actually taken seriously we're
used in a fun way like really yeah and
also it definitely seems like a testing
ground for x-force because they're gonna
make the x-force movie with Josh Brolin
and Ryan Reynolds it's and like you see
them on a plane and you see like Terry
Crews and you can have negasonic teenage
warhead and you had Ricky Baker from
yeah which I wish that movie people yeah
yeah he beats Domino is so cool I love
her hair teased out and I'm just excited
to see her cuz she's great on Atlanta
and I'm glad that she's getting her do
you yeah I think the more fun they can
have with time travel in these
storylines the better the the I love
like Back to the Future Part 2 because
they almost had like a meta
kind of approach to time-travel whereas
the first Back to the Future was like
kind of serious about time share for the
second ones like let's just get silly
with it so the way Days of Future past
was
pretty serious about time travel I would
love to see this this x-men universe
story that's just kind of light-hearted
about it that would be actually really
funny nobody bad and I like the they use
some slow-mo here and I love that
opening shot from the first we were like
that you're moving through the car
accident like in that split-second yes
John wick director so the action is
gonna be on something at the very least
reactions gonna be good so yeah well
yeah take a look at our trailer
breakdown of this for everything that
you might have missed let us know what
you think about this one in the comments
and and yeah let's move on to the final
trailer that we drop this week breakdown
is now on the channel of venom starring
Tom Hardy and yeah we have some thoughts
on this but let's take a look at this
fan made trail I mean legit trailer
that's not just Tom Hardy in other
movies
it seems it to the trailer here Oxana I
get cold feet - relatable
again
everyone's got this my favorite part of
the room as as sold as a Nick wait for
it if you mean all of AZ shoulders and
necks Rico
whatever it is you used to be one thing
now you're something about turns
howard's voiceover of this trip i really
now it's a sample
why is it
honey we all have our own it's real bad
our own issues
demons
nice
three super Oh Jacqueline
okay I don't mind
oh yeah look I guess I can be the leg oh
oh you like the name venom yeah I think
it's trying to be the dark knight of the
Marvel of spider-man world what is
directed by the guy who did Sambi lands
so they should they're reading into the
wrong part of what makes him a good
director or or the the part that fans
like about his directing yeah I'm not
sure what the tone of this movie's gonna
like Zombieland did kind of walk that
line between funny and scary but this
doesn't really feel like either it feels
like yeah I'm not laughing I'm not
particularly scared the I think this is
a true teaser we should say this is a
teaser and I think we've all been a bit
spoiled by the by the idea of like being
overloaded with fanservice and these
trailers where every shot is full of
something the way that those 30 seconds
of of interest infinity war was but the
this feels like a present Christmas and
they complain about it all right you got
a present all right just socks right
socks are helpful venom is happening Tom
Hardy is in it there's a you know they
got a good actor for it there's a that's
what it is season the flash season the
classic catchphrases we are we're all
the flash and makes no sense in context
I said well I my concern with this one
is that we have had so many superhero
movies now we have had deck like over a
decade obviously be hero more than when
was the first one if you consider x-men
in 2000 Tim Burton's Batman amazing like
a decade of solid superhero movies and
what you're seeing with Thor which was
just like you know what what we're doing
is not working let's inject it full of
Kiwi humor you know and now with Black
Panther it's like no boundaries let's go
all in let's just you know so my culture
not only a movie but a movement I know
I'm just worried cuz we have had so many
spider-man interpretations when
figurations that we can't have the same
thing it
be playing it safe yeah and this kind of
felt a bit safe in terms what didn't
feel r-rated for sure and that was kind
of I don't know if it's been confirmed
that it's gonna be our rated I didn't
see any violence whereas Deadpool the
trailer didn't shy away from the
violence of the profanity had celebrated
that whereas this just feels like this
could have been a PG rated movie I
didn't really get a sense of how vicious
or violent this moves gonna be I mean
carnage is rumored to be the villain of
this movie and this does not seem like
the kind of movie that carnage would be
in I think I'm getting a like a Jason
Bourne vibe of you like on the run with
this you can have it r-rated you have it
super violent because it could be like a
dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde which is kind of
sometimes what venom is where it just
kind of like comes out of it you can't
control it and then what you do is
because this is based on a story where
you kind of like a piece of venomous
taken away and they try to make soldiers
out of it so you get carnage from there
and carnage is basically like the the
blood hound that goes after him and it's
like oh no that could be very scary and
very violent fast very but yeah I bet
again teaser it's hard to like right it
shouldn't be too hard on it yeah yeah
but I think the I think what's clear
from this teaser is that the studio is
very excited I think as we all should be
about Tom Hardy playing this character
it's it's rare that you see a physical
heavyweight of an actor take on this
kind of role and it's a venom is I'm
sure for you it's it's one of the most
exciting it's exciting about characters
from all of comics so I think we want to
make sure it's done right and I think
they nailed the casting for it I'm
excited to see what he can do with it I
think they want us to be like no would
it like just trust us on the visual
effects they'll be there by the time you
watch this movie but Tom Hardy is gonna
be bringing the psychology of this
character to the screen and that's
something we should be excited about in
time we do have Topher Grace skyping in
with his feedback and he was he was
great I liked him and he was the best
part of a very muddled movie at
spider-man 3 that's part what the
dancing was the best part yeah that's on
a completely different grading scale
it's your move
oh my god you are Tobey Maguire just
right there yeah just right then that
bagel boy I'm just him right there also
they used the classic Marvel logo and
not the new one not the new Marvel
Studios and so it's like everyone here
because Marvel will return Sony's calls
or tell them what the actual timeline of
these movies are supposed to be eight
years later are you crazy
yeah anywho yeah I think this comes out
October I'll watch it I any broken load
yeah lock and load
Oh rockin Lloyd I thought we're going
back to the turd jokes first second
alright I was confused you know you say
it was like a Bourne Identity what are
we doing nervous moonwalking out of here
so we agree venom favorite trailer venom
yeah favorite yeah I think it might have
been a mistake to feel the need to
release the venom sure we know the
movies happening this is a big week
obviously for trailers of course we're
gonna compare these to these other great
trailers that we got why would you need
to release a little underwhelming teaser
you're right I could have done it two
weeks ago a lot of people we're saying
they're like we need a venom trailer I'm
like really it's October when it grows
out get a solo trailer first week at it
you're happy yes screaming um well of
all these seven trailers which one do
you think yeah
Deadpool was super fun ed pull Deadpool
I think got me the most excited for it I
think Westworld might have been like the
most like oh this trailer itself might
win awards because of the way it's
edited but Avengers hey everything else
yeah Jessica Jones hmm well the will be
doing breakdowns and check out our
channel uh as I said before we have
breakdowns for all of these find all the
Easter eggs that you might have missed
and yeah once these things come out
we'll be doing deep dives and to
everything so let us know what you found
to be your favorite to all these
trailers which ones left you wanting
more which ones made you think maybe I
won't check this though but five by the
way I just realized with Black Panthers
trailer probably playing during the big
game - or
after that's five different Marvel
properties and then two of two of those
are from a different company that's
still making a Marvel property yeah guys
what a time to be alive well thank you
for checking out this video make sure to
tune in next week for new rockstars news
it's obviously a very different style of
video we're doing this week just because
there's such a huge week and we wanted
to talk about everything with you guys
but yeah make sure to follow all of us
on on Twitter I'm Erik Bosse a TiVo us
at Sam Bosch sure you can follow me
there also I got a Captain America First
Avenger breakdown coming out on this
channel very soon so look out for that
and then Avengers it's an MCU rewatch
series it's very fun oh yeah oh hi I'm
Garrett you can follow along when I talk
geeky things and talk with Sam more at
geek balm yep and guys next week is I
know I'm trying something I don't know
Black Panthers coming out next week guys
so stay tuned for that subscribe to this
channel like this video share it around
follow us on Twitter at new rockstars
thanks guys see you next week